I think you may have heard this line
before
I asked for Guinness and he gave me beer
that is an iambic pentameter it is
natural for an English speaker to speak
in tenby lines Shakespeare wasn't the
first to use blank verse and as soon as
he gets familiar with it he breaks the
rule and the rule is always broken
because of an emotional change because
another character comes into the room or
because a character is a different
status speaks only the early plays are
strictly blank verse
the biggest help for any actor coming to
Shakespeare for the first time
is to look
how words in opposition to each other
words in contradiction to each other or
words in complement to each other are in
the text because that is Shakespeare
giving you stepping stones throughout
the text
there's no right or wrong there's only
clearer
it will be clearer
when in disgrace with fortune and men's
eyes I all alone beweep my outcasts
State and troubled death heaven with my
bootless cries and look upon myself and
curse my fate wishing me like to one
more rich in Hope
featured like him like him with friends
possessed Desiring this man's art and
that man's scope with what I most enjoy
content at least
then in these thoughts myself almost
despising
happily I think on thee and then my
state like to the locker break of day
arising from Sullen Earth sings hymns at
Heaven's Gate
for thy Sweet Love remembered
such Wellsprings that then I scorned to
change my state with Kings
welcome back to the studio where with
the help of our actors Cam and Brooke
we'll start to explore the specific
tools that modern actors use in
rehearsal to unlock Shakespeare's verse
and bring Shakespeare's plays to life on
stage
today's actors must figure out how to
honor the complex language Shakespeare
wrote for his characters while still
making it sound natural and spontaneous
for most actors this takes a lot of
practice
and just like an audience member
attending a Shakespeare play for the
first time actors approaching
Shakespeare sometimes find the verse a
bit intimidating at the beginning of
their training
Brooke and cam I'm curious whether that
was true for you
well I think it's interesting because
yes it is a challenge to grasp on to the
heightened language in the beginning but
I think with more experience and skill
building and practice like you say you
learn a whole lot more that about how
Shakespeare left in certain cubes and
breadcrumbs to lead you down the way and
eventually you can learn how to act it
well
great Brooke I think the biggest
challenge is just making sure that the
audience understands you and also the
biggest fear
um can they get the story am I
communicating the language clearly to
them but as Cam said there's breadcrumbs
throughout and if you
honor and respect and trust that the
language is there and it starts to feel
more natural yeah I agree at the
beginning of my career when I started to
act Shakespeare at first I also felt
like the rhythm of the verse trapped me
a little bit I was afraid it would sound
sing-songy or unnatural because when I
spoke it aloud I wanted to hit the
Rhythm in which it appears on the page
but as I gained more experience over
time I realized that the rhythm of the
verse was actually just there to support
my acting and not to hinder it gives you
more freedom yeah than actually yeah it
provides the freedom to work within that
structure
so let's talk about how the verse itself
works and begin exploring how actors
decode it
first of all Shakespeare writes his
plays in a form called blank verse also
known as I am but pentameter this just
means that one verse line is made up of
ten beats positioned in a roughly
unstressed stressed pattern let me
demonstrate using two simple but pretty
famous lines
but soft what light through yonder
window breaks it is the East and Juliet
is the Sun
listen again
but soft what light through yonder
window breaks it is the East and Jewel
yet is the Sun so you can hear that the
words just fall out in that Rhythm but
soft what light through yonder window
breaks it is the East and Juliet is the
Sun
that's not only because Shakespeare knew
how to arrange the words in such a way
that they fall out like that it's also
because the verse pattern is very close
to the way a lot of the English language
naturally falls out of our mouths
elizabethans didn't walk around worrying
about whether their words were spoken in
verse of course but they did happen to
speak a language that naturally lent
itself to the patterns found in iambic
pentameter in fact it would sound
strange if we tried not to use an iambic
Rhythm to say those two lines
but soft what light through yawn Derwin
can you hear how much work it takes to
say that thought aloud without giving in
to the Natural iambic Rhythm so we could
go so far as to say that Shakespeare
wasn't doing anything particularly
mysterious by using iambic pentameter he
was just going with the flow of the
language he spoke
another way of saying this is
Shakespeare is very good at placing
words in a verse line that reflects and
enhances the English language's natural
iambic tendency
we're going to explore this idea a bit
further by clapping out a simple iambic
Rhythm together feel free to do this
along with us
are we ready
if you keep doing this you might find
that you can think of simple thoughts
that fall out with that Rhythm just
because of the way we pronounce and
stress certain syllables in the words we
use every day for example
I'm hungry and I'd like to eat some
lunch that's iambic pentameter
so Brook and cam can you think of a
couple sentences that fall out in iambic
pentameter
last night I had a dream you ran away
great it just happens to fall out
iambically due to the way we stress
syllables cam I'm sleepy so I need to
take a nap but if I sleep too long it
could be bad
what else do you notice about the rhythm
of the verse
it mimics the rhythm of the human
heartbeat doesn't it so not only does
the English language often happen to
fall out of our mouths in iambic
pentameter anyway but we're also
carrying iambic Rhythm around in our
bodies all the time we just didn't know
to call it that
one more thing I find Shakespeare easier
to memorize when I'm in motion so
sometimes I Pace the floor while I'm
working on memorization and at some
point I realized while doing that
but soft what light through yonderwind
dough breaks
heel toe heel toe heel toe heel toe
it turns out that Shakespeare is also
utilizing a rhythm that we carry in our
footfalls
if actors can learn to think of
Shakespeare's verse form blank verse as
something that they already carry in
their physical bodies rather than a rule
they have to learn they can start to
make his language their own
now we don't want to get too hung up on
the rhythm of the verse right away
Shakespeare does a good job making that
work and he doesn't need the actors to
overdo it and we Now understand that the
rhythm is already in us as English
speakers anyway
[Music]